au début de sa relation la jeune femme
pensait avoir rencontré l'homme de sa
vie c'était quelqu'un de très charmant
au début de de souriants de jovial mais
très vite les mots doux ont fait place à
des remarques blessantes ça va être un
gros cul va faire du sport chérie enfin
des petites choses voilà ça commence
comme ça et après ça se termine en bas
je vais être crever tu vas crever avec
tes gosses de merde
jusqu'au jour où les premiers coups sont
tombés pendant des années clémence a été
littéralement tabassé un soir elle a
même frôlé la mort
merci Marlène Schiappa d'être avec nous
et c'est vrai que ce documentaire
vraiment c'est un documentaire choc je
lis le mot n'est vrai c'est incroyable
merci Marlène en tout cas d'être là et
merci pour l'idée parce que comme vous
avez vu ce doc pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent en direct ce soir
bonsoir d'abord merci de m'avoir invité
en fait c'est une discussion qu'on a eu
ensemble avec vous Cyril je disais que
les chaînes de télé s'engageaient pas
assez pour soutenir les femmes face aux
violences et que le 25 novembre c'est la
Journée mondiale pour l'élimination des
violences à l'égard des femmes et que
c'était un bon moment pour s'engager et
donc je suis allée voir Maxime Saada qui
a tout de suite été partant pour voilà
exactement pour qui a été partant pour
qu'on puisse faire ce documentaire qui
est produit par H2O et qui est réalisé
par Jean-Michel Gomez que je veux saluer
parce qu'il a fait un travail incroyable
alors on va vous montrer des images de
documentaire dans un instant et des
extraits vous allez voir
extrêmement fort vous avez donc lancé ce
projet je crois que c'était on s'est ému
je crois que c'était un mois un mois et
demi
vous avez même animé le soir de Virgin
Radio hier soir avec Guillaume gentil et
sachez que il y a eu énormément de
demandes de témoignages hier sur les
missions de Marlène avec avec Guillaume
ce qui prouve que il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes qui veulent parler
qui veulent briser ce tabou et qui
veulent et je vous dis on a on n'a pas
pu et malheureusement hier ils ont pas
pu prendre tout le monde ce qu'on a eu
énormément de demandes on le refera bien
entendu j'espère qu'on le refera parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui voulaient
parler à notre secrétaire d'État mais
c'est vrai que c'est ça avancé très vite
et aujourd'hui
Marlène se documentaire c'est vrai que
vous l'avez porté vous
c'est qu'est-ce que vous diriez au
téléspectateurs pour qu'il regarde ce
soir parce que c'est vrai que on a envie
qu'il soit vu par le plus grand nombre
de personnes d'abord je veux prévenir
que c'est un documentaire vraiment enfin
pour ceux qui l'ont vu qui prend au
tripes voilà c'est pas édulcoré on a
voulu montrer vraiment la réalité des
violences sans filtre et ce sont des
violences particulières parce que ce
sont des violences qui se produisent
quand on est dans l'endroit dans lequel
on devrait être le plus en sécurité
c'est-à-dire chez soi et par la personne
qu'on aime ou en tout cas avec laquelle
on a choisi de vivre à un moment qui
serait censé nous aimer nous protéger
nous rassurer et qui en fait nous
frappent et on entend voilà on a
vraiment voulu on n'a pas voulu mentir
on n'a pas voulu édulcorer la réalité
des violences donc ça peut être parfois
voilà ça prend aux tripes mais c'était
aussi pour nous une manière de montrer
les dispositifs d'aide de mettre à
l'honneur les associations de montrer le
travail de la police il y a 400 000
interventions par an de la police et de
la gendarmerie pour sauver des femmes et
des enfants face aux violences intra
familiales et on a voulu montrer tout
simplement la quantité d'app au secours
qu'il reçoive et c'est vrai que c'est
assez glaçon
les équipes de tournage sont allés
rencontrer des agents de police qui
reçoivent les plaintes de violences
conjugales regardez
qui a été créé en 2018 des discussions
en ligne anonymes ils sont 40 gendarmes
et policiers à être connecté 24 heures
sur 24 là c'est une personne qui me dit
que son conjoint l'a frappé elle me dit
que c'est pas la première fois donc elle
me dit qu'elle est dans les toilettes
etc donc là je vais prendre toutes les
informations clairement elle n'a pas pu
appeler le 17 parce que il y a quelqu'un
dans le dans le domicile donc sûrement
qu'elle n'aurait prévenu personne et
qu'elle voilà elle aurait subi ces
violences encore aujourd'hui quoi grâce
à ces échanges discrets et accessible
depuis un smartphone ou une tablette
des milliers de femmes ont pu être
secourus
il y a une plateforme de chat dans le
cas où la victime sera proximité de son
goût et c'est vrai que ce documentaire
Marlène vraiment il faut le voir et je
vous dis ça s'enchaînera directement
avec TPMP il y aura pas de pub entre les
deux émissions et surtout ne manquez pas
le début du documentaire qui est
vraiment c'est un début malheureusement
de
film on a l'impression d'être dans un
film Géraldine
choc en fait et de la même manière que
ces femmes prennent des coups et son
meurtrie moi en tant que télépectatrice
j'ai pris un uppercut vraiment et je me
suis dit que c'était un documentaire
vraiment d'utilité publique je vais le
montrer à mes filles 19 et 17 parce que
je pense que c'est très important je
vais montrer à mon fils qui a 15 ans
parce que je trouve que c'est très
important d'éduquer aussi les nouvelles
générations à aux relations homme-femme
à comment on doit se comporter les
phénomènes d'emprise pas que la violence
physique mais aussi la violence des mots
la violence économique et tout ça et
franchement j'ai trouvé que c'était un
documentaire exceptionnel franchement
très important les équipements aussi
rencontré des médecins qui accueillent
ces victimes constater les BG sur
reçoivent chaque jour des témoignages
très violents de la part de ces femmes
regardent
parce que j'ai le problème avec mon
ex-mari d'accord je suis séparé de lui
mais lui il n'arrête pas de m'en lancer
d'accord il a brûlé quatre femmes en
maison il a jeté leçon même ses enfants
il est dedans elle voulait me tuer parce
que c'est un psychopathe
quand il vous frappe quel genre de coup
il vous donne une fois là j'étais le
couteau
dans le bras et lui comme ça il a jeté
le couteau directement si je fais pas
comme ça dans la tête elle peut
oui il aurait pu vous toucher d'accord
il a pas touché mon visage il a touché
mon bras d'accord
alors dans ce foyer on va voir on avait
un foyer
en Essonne documentaire ce soir et il y
a également des ateliers qui sont mis en
place pour aider les femmes à reprendre
confiance en elle notamment un atelier
de boxe et vous allez voir Marlène
Schiappa je peux vous dire que elle
cogne fort la marine
vous avez été faire un petit peu de box
je n'arriverai pas à rompre la planche
tout à l'heure ça c'est 22 années de
travail
un cours de boxe à proprement parler il
y a vraiment une recherche derrière je
vais à la je reviens je repars
déjà
bravo bravo bravo moi je fais du judo le
montant et c'est vrai que je sais que
dans la rue je vais pas faire une prise
de judo à un gars mais le fait de savoir
que je sais le faire en fait ça me donne
une posture je trouve ouais une posture
une assurance une position de corps
aussi on montre mais ça il le voit aussi
dans la rue les agresseurs souvent ils
s'en prennent pas à n'importe qui faut
pas croire
c'est très fort
et on met sur ce fléau des visages des
voix parce que des enregistrements et ce
que j'ai bien aimé aussi c'est les
solutions que vous apportez notamment la
plateforme et par exemple vous expliquer
je ne le savais pas que quand une femme
est en train de chatter pour dire son
malheur et que le mari qui peut la taper
rentre et bien ça s'efface directement
donc il voit pas qu'elle était en train
de justement de dialoguer avec les
policiers
donc dès qu'on l'entend arriver enfin on
peut même ça s'appelle arrêtons les
violences.gouv.fr on peut même le faire
sur son téléphone on chat et s'il arrive
on se déconnecte il y a une autre page
lambda qui apparaît sur l'écran et ça
n'apparaît pas sur l'historique donc
pour toutes les femmes comme le disait
très justement Géraldine qui sont
surveillés ou qui sont sous emprise
c'est possible pour elle d'appeler à
l'aide discrètement d'ailleurs la dame
me dit un moment dit je suis enfermée
dans les toilettes j'entends qu'il
arrive aidez-moi elle donne son adresse
conjugales on en parle souvent mais ça
reste quelque chose d'abstrait pour
plein de gens et là le fait d'entendre
des vraies scènes de violence le fait de
voir aussi des reconstructions
les plus forts voilà parce que vous
connaissez H2O production et de parce
que voilà c'est vrai que donc mon poste
on les a mis ce soir parce qu'on voulait
pas voilà aussi choc hein
je pense qu'il faut les montrer il faut
les entendre et c'est révoltant et quand
on voit ça on a envie d'agir et on se
dit malheureusement qu'on connaît sans
doute dans notre entourage tous des
femmes peut-être sans le savoir qui sont
victimes de ces violences et c'est c'est
terrible ce qui est intéressant
également dans le documentaire c'est que
parfois on imagine la femme battue
forcément avec un cocard avec un bleu et
on le voit et donc elle est elle est
visible dans l'espace public or elles ne
sont pas forcément toutes visibles dans
l'espace public c'est ce qui est montré
parce que il y a effectivement le viol
conjugal qui est abordé dans dans le
documentaire il y a les violences
verbales psychologiques et tout ça aussi
donc c'est aussi une forme d'éducation
pour tous ceux qui écoutent et qui
regardent et notamment à l'adresse des
plus jeunes ils peuvent pas se rendre
compte parfois peut-être ça sera ce soir
sur C8 juste après
Touche pas à mon poste en tout cas bravo
Marlène je sais pas non mais c'est vrai
Marlène c'est son idée qui avait été
voilà moi je moi je l'ai suivi elle
donne souvent des idées et puis après
nous on la suit